welcome to the heavy spoiler show I'm
your host Paul in this video we're
breaking down hasb been
[Music]
Hotel the brand new series is now out
and I can't wait to get into what
happens at the end H boss is of course a
spinoff of it and throughout this video
we're going to be breaking it all down
and talking about a potential season 2
Heavy spoilers ahead so if you haven't
had a chance to check it out then I
highly recommend that you check out now
if you enjoy this video please please
hit the thumbs up and make sure you
subscribe for videos like this every
week without way a huge thank you for
clicking this now let's get into hasb
been Hotel wait
[Music]
you [__] okay so we begin with the tale
narrating the story of Lucifer and
what's happening in hell we learn that
heaven was ruled by beings of pure light
and we see their depictions as being
like eyes with rings around them this is
how the Angels were initially depicted
in the Bible and this is what was also
used as a design for the the Wormhole
engine in Event Horizon here we also
learn of Lucifer and his ideas for
creation which led to him being
ostracized out due them clashing with
the other angels on Earth they created
Adam and Lilith with a former demanding
control bleeing the Garden of Eden
Lilith was drawn in by Lucifer with the
two Rebels and falling in love Lucifer
then gave the gift of knowledge to Eve
but with this brought evil to Earth the
order Heaven maintain was broken and
they cast Lucifer out and made it so he
couldn't watch the outcome of his goals
on Earth he ended up deep depressed but
Lilith created a kingdom of Hell however
heaven was worried about this and thus
every year they stormed the domain so
that they couldn't rise up this is a
Great Purge that wipes out hell's over
population problem and makes it so they
can't build an army now this is where
Charlie Morning Star comes in who we
learn is the daughter of Lucifer and
Lilith We join her in the aftermath of
another extermination and Ln Lilith's
been missing for seven years heading up
the hasbin hotel Charlie's created this
to be a sort of Rehabilitation Center
for Sinners Charlie wants to find a way
to deal with the overp population and
here she'll help Souls redeem themselves
so they're accepted into heaven helped
by her girlfriend vaggie ad star Angel D
and bomman husk along with a couple of
others they go through the ring air
trying to get through it all Keith David
plays husk and I love seeing him pop up
throughout the songs are incredible too
and throughout the season we watches
Charlie has to deal with the hells and
lows of running a hotel more like ho
hell he now it's important to bear in
mind that there is a pilot for the
series out on YouTube that kind of sets
up the events of the season I don't
think it's completely necessary to watch
it because the show does a good job of
taking away the homework and Bal down to
its most basic plot points it sees
Charlie setting up the hotel and
checking in the first person that goes
through the ringer that is Angel D and
we also meet Alistar who wants to help
create an advert which is how season one
starts episode one picks up the week
after that and Charlie's asked by her
dad to go on his place at the annual
Heaven meeting laughed out the boardroom
we then learn the next Purge has been
moved up to 6 months it's discovered
that Adam Wants Revenge in the domain
and throughout the series we see as
Charlie tries to stop this Adam's mad
because one of his exterminators were
killed which we learn was because
Carmela was trying to protect her
daughter along the way we also meet
characters like serenus and his group of
little egg minions Charlie wants to put
him on the path to becoming a good egg
and they add some real complexities to
the characters in the show that's most
notably seen in Angel D who we learns
being abused by his boss Valentino angel
dust wants to go through with it because
he wants to be broken to the point
Valentino will think he's used up and
then finally let him go husk has a
darker pass too with him once being an
Overlord with a gambling addiction this
leted him taking a deal with Alistar
andless the pair are more similar than
they initially thought eventually
Lucifer organizes another meeting with
Charlie and the forces of Heaven here
they meet Sarah and Emily the both of
which are sarapin we also learn that
vagi used to be an exterminator and that
she was cast out after refusing to kill
a sinner child Adam threatens to tell
Charlie but in many ways it shows that
there are ways to Redemption this is
seen in angel dust 2 who tells Valentino
that outside of the studio he doesn't
control him this highlights that one can
be redeemed even if a court in heaven
finds no evidence that it's possible
however it's clear that chol's please
have an impact as Emily sides with her
after learning the truth about what's
going on turns out that even angels
don't know how Souls enter Heaven
showing that they don't even grasp the
concept themselves sent back to hell
Adam promises Charlie that when the
extermination begins that the hotel will
be the first thing they go to and that
takes us into final two episodes the one
character I haven't mentioned so far is
Nifty who works as the hotel's cook she
sort of becomes the hero of the finale
the little psychopath but it's clear
Charlie believes she could have done
better episode 7 begins dealing with the
aftermath of six with the revelations
leaving her bedridden Alistar mocks her
and I think it's pronounced Alistar but
but spelled store which I've checked and
I'm going to sound like an idiot as well
so you're probably mocking me and but
alistor comes there and and when all
hope seems lost he takes her to cannibal
town this is to fight against that
incoming threat and though it's called
that it looks pretty nice I'd pay an
alal leg to hang out thereo you suck to
get to it Charlie has to make a quote
unquote deal with the devil and I
believe this is what's going to put him
in the hot seat in the final episode we
can see he's got designs are ruling over
hell and I'll talk about later on where
I think this is going to go now killed
me when she was getting heckled by that
old woman and on the other side of this
vagi goes to Cara to ask how to kill
Angels Learning that the secret to
ending exterminators Li in the Angelic
steel these weapons are capable of
killing other angels we get two bangers
back to back and then from here go into
the finale title The Show Must Go On
preparation for the fight begins with
cherry bomb also joining the heroes or
baddies or whatever what we really
learned though is Charlie's suspicions
were indeed right and that demons do
indeed want to be good the next day the
slaughter begins with the forces of Hell
actually seeming like they stand a
chance however the loss is coming
quickly with aliser fading away after
almost losing the fight love the tvhe
headed Vox celebrating and a maybe one
day we'll see video kill the Radio Star
The Egg boys get scrambled and suenes
rushes to attack Adam with the death ray
after declaring his love to Cherry hope
seems lost though and it's easily
defeated but this empowers Charlie to
reach a new level of demon she is of
course her mother and father's daughter
and on the other side of this we see
vaggy sparing loot although Lucifer has
been apathetic throughout the show we
sees he returns to help save his
daughter fighting against Adam the parab
of course had beef since the Garden of
Eden with Lucifer being M attempt your
girls beating him to a pulp Charlie ends
up stepping in before he deals a killing
blow this is where Nifty comes into play
though and she steps in and stabs him
several times leading to a retreat the
extermination being cancelled but
Charlie still regrets at the dreams of
the hotel have been ruined comforted by
her father they then start to rebuild it
which will become a beacon of the new
path to Redemption that the demons can
now take now speaking of New Paths we
could to Alistar who announces that he
wishes to become the leader of hell it's
clear we're going to be getting that in
season 2 along with a number of things
coming down from heaven up there we see
s penes has arrived showing that it is
possible for demons to be redeemed
sacrificing himself is what got him up
there and thus the others can do it if
they're able to act Noble on top of this
we also close out with a big teaser and
learn that Lilith's in fact been in
Heaven All Along lud is now the leader
in the wake of Adam's death and she says
that if she wants to stay there she'll
have to stop her daughter obviously it's
going to be a family affair and I
actually feel the way stuff goes might
end up shocking you sounds like a
clickbait headline that and to be fair
there's a lot of clickbait on the
channel but I think that with this
season's opening we can make some
predictions Alister clearly wants to
become the ruler of hell and I actually
think this might happen Charlie of
course owes him a dead and I believe
that he's going to come to collect it I
will s through time that Lilith will
return to hell and convince her daughter
to join her in heaven Lucifer could come
along too and this would bring things
full circle from him being cast out
however they might do the complete
opposite and have her realize her family
is where her heart is and have her go
back to hell to take care of her
daughter sort of sort of giving you both
possible options there but if you think
there's another way then please drop it
below as for season 2 we know it's
coming soon and actually have a post
from the main voice actress that is
Erica henningson who plays the lead
character Charlie Morning Star at the
end of January she posted out an
Instagram story saying that she was back
in the recording booth and doing season
2 we've had Rumblings this is coming for
a while with the first trailer even
announcing in the description That
season 2 was a go I'm not sure how long
this stuff takes to make though and
we've of course had number push backs
due to the strikes season one was
delayed because of Co and I'm hoping
that they've got things in play so we're
not going through a massive weight
rumors at the moment though are that we
may get season 2 towards mid 2025 now
going Beyond this there is the thought
that Amazon actually took what was one
season and split it into two in order to
mean there wasn't as much of a gap
however this has left some fans worry
that two seasons being green lit like
this might lead to us not actually
getting a season 3 I do think the show
will succeed though and it's been posted
on X which I hate it's been posted on
Twitter will say by the official account
that this is the largest global debut
for a new animated series you will
notice that Studios do this a lot and
the L things is like I don't know
biggest show released on the second
Tuesday of the month between 1:00 a.m.
or 3: or something and there's obviously
some spin to it but headlines like this
especially with stuff like Invincible on
the platform they do seem good so yeah
season 2 is definitely coming and if
you've enjoy this video and want to help
out the channel we currently have a
membership thing where you can donate 99
pens or 99 cents a month and get early
access to videos all our classic movie
breakdowns get released there early and
huge thank you to everyone who signed up
cuz the comments they really mean a lot
to me look at this guy he's bloody
loving it less than $12 a year mental
and just click that join button if you
want to do it and thank you for all your
love now as what my thoughts on the
series I'm going to tell you where I am
mentally I don't like musicals and I
find them mature with there only being
two that I'm actually able to sit
through those are the greatest showman
in eight8 mile but add this to the list
yet cuz what we've got here it's another
bloody Banger absolutely love the songs
that they use throughout the season and
would happily listen to them as their
own Standalone album they brilliantly
depict what the characters are going
through and also cover a number of
musical genres at a really high level
think at this point a24 are my favorite
Studio out right now and they constantly
continue to knock it out the park
whether it's films or even animated
shows you know you're always going to
get a high level of quality that's what
I think the shout is too and if you're
watching this without seeing it then I
recommend you check it out this was a
great first season and I can't wait to
see what happens down the line so yeah
highly recommend it and make sure you
leave your thoughts below please drop a
like on the video and if you want to get
some heavy spoilers merch we've also got
our t-shirt line located below the video
this will let you pick up all kinds of
tops like our Theory time one Marvel and
a lot more we drop new designs on there
all the time too so definitely keep an
eye out and thank you for your support
if you want some else to watch you got a
video on screen right now so definitely
head over there right after this by the
way huge thank you for sing through the
video I've been your host Paul and I'll
see you next time take care peace